can you say something about how you like
to fuel
your like whether it's race or great
training sessions like maybe the day
before
let's go even that far during and maybe
a few hours after okay it'll be a little
different
for racing than it will be for like a
big workout just because
the interesting thing about ultra
running is just like you never do the
race even
like most endurance races you're going
to cover the distance you're going to
replicate the race almost up to it
in training whereas with 100 miles you
can't you might replicate a third of it
so so i'll do i'll walk you through kind
of my approach
for like 100 mile race and i can tell
you maybe what i would do differently on
like a training day
uh but yeah so for um
where where the community is in
agreement is that you do want to be
very good at burning fat for
ultramarathons i mean there's just like
the intensity is low
if you're if your ratios are skewed
very high towards carbohydrate
metabolism
then you're going to have to defend your
muscle glycogen
through tons of carbohydrate consumption
and
that's just going to be very hard to do
over the course of an entire day even at
low intensities
so it's a fuel tank thing i mean it's
like your your leanest endurance
athletes have way more fat than they do
glycogen stores
when you're doing low intensity
performance you want to be burning high
levels of fat and sparing that muscle
glycogen
what i tend to do is i want to start the
race burning really high levels of fat
so
i'm gonna i'll maybe have some
carbohydrate the night before for dinner
but then i'm gonna lean into the
overnight fast breakfast the morning of
i'm gonna stay away from carbohydrates
for a hundred miler anyway
and i'm gonna have something like
something that's pretty
like uh high energy low
volume so like i'll do like an s fuels
uh life bar
they've got like what's in an s fuel
life bar are we talking about carbs or
we're talking about
proteins basically fat and protein yeah
fat protein bar
and it makes sense that's awesome yeah
so it's it's not it's low carb
yeah they make s fuels makes a whole
product line that's like kind of
positioned for a low-carb athlete so
they have some products on their lineup
that
offer some carbohydrate which is perfect
for me because i do introduce some
carbohydrate on racing and some of my
bigger training sessions and things
but the majority of their products are
low carb
uh so like they have like you know how
you get like the powders that you put
into like your drinks that are like
high carbohydrate you know sports
products they make a version of that
that's uh
like fat based oh cool that you can mix
in with water yep
cool yeah so they've got like a creamer
version and then a fruity flavored
version so you can like replicate the
taste and the feel of drinking like a
like you know a sports drink science is
awesome i know it is
well and that's so much of it too
because people are always like well i
don't know i just i
just like to have my gatorade or
whatever right yeah it's like well you
can have it now just uh it won't have
all that you can see you can bring that
kind of thing with you
yeah so i'm leaning on a lot of those
like kind of liquid calories like those
low
volume high energy fat protein stuff the
morning of so that when i start the race
my body's gonna be encouraged to
start out burning high levels of fat
once i get going
probably 45 minutes in i'll start
introducing small amounts of
carbohydrate so at that point my
body's been revving pretty high fat
metabolism
and by introducing some carbohydrate in
the context of the
you know let's say my hundred mile uh
personal record
you know i'm i'm running approximately
nine miles every hour so
i'm probably going through about a
thousand calories in an hour's time
uh i'm gonna start just like defending
muscle glycogen
by burning super high levels of fat at
the heart rate i would do for that i'm
probably burning somewhere between 80 90
percent fat
you know 12 hours of that you can chip
away at your muscle glycogen
uh to the point where you don't
necessarily want to go zero carb
so i'm basically just trying to defend
what i know i'm going to be burning from
the
carbohydrate side of that 80 to 90
percent fat 10 to 20
carbohydrate by taking in like usually
you know i've gone as low as about 15
grams of carbohydrate per hour and as
high as 40 grams
and the reality is somewhere in between
is probably the sweet spot but
40 i can get away without any digestion
issues
so i'm not really concerned pushing up
to that during a race since i'm
only concerned about performance on that
is it the car's that's the problem or is
it fiber
or just oh from going above 40 grams or
just because you mentioned digestion
issues
like one of the things for me it's like
one of the
cool things about fatty protein protein
or fat
is like my stomach just feels way better
yeah like for
so like carbs introduce like bloating
and just not feeling great
yeah and i think the funny thing is like
if you look at the position paper for
ultra marathon single day events and
it's
you know it's very limited in the sense
that and it's not anyone's fault it's
just we don't have a lot of great
research on 100 mile races it's really
hard to study what's going on when
someone's running a hundred miles
but they'll say moderate carbohydrate
diet
is recommended but they'll also say that
it's like something like sixty percent
of participants are going to report some
sort of like digestion issue during the
event
so then it kind of becomes an issue do
you want to flip that coin do you want
to flip that coin
40 right exactly so for me what i found
is like
i can push up to 40 grams without
getting any digestion issues
um do i need 40 grams probably not at
least not
based on kind of the numbers that would
be like that that i would see on like if
i went and actually got
like a metabolic heart test or something
like that um but it's possible i mean if
i had a really good race that i would
get close to burning that per hour
um most folks that are following a
moderate high carbohydrate are going to
be recommended do like 50 to 70 grams
during a single day ultra marathon event
and
you'll see some you know some
recommendations of up to like 100 grams
not so much for ultra marathons but just
in general from like a performance
standpoint which
i mean it's one of those things where
it's like application versus
like what you can do in a lab for one
hour is going to be a lot different
especially when you're stretching out
distances well past that and you
there's there's i'm diverting a little
here but i mean there's like an approach
of like training your gut so you can
like
be able to tolerate that much
carbohydrate which you can do and you
may have to if you're gonna follow a
high carbohydrate diet
but again we go back to that
practicality standpoint of
if you're a professional olympian who's
living and breathing performance
and you're burning two to three times
you're messing
resting metabolic rate on some days like
you
you may be able to actually consume 100
grams of carbohydrate per hour during
your training sessions and
and just you know barely stay on top of
your nutritional needs
most people who are running
ultramarathons aren't going to be you
know probably training much past 10
hours per week
and they're probably not going to have
the i'll call it their
a dietary budget to tolerate 100 grams
of carbohydrate consumption during their
workouts and still be able to
stay healthy and you know so i think
that's kind of like a
a bit of a of a non a non-starter for
the majority of people
unless we want to talk about like a tiny
percentage of the one percent of
top performers
you